let's see how you can create a password
field in HTML we create the label and
input elements in our HTML file we add
an ID attribute to the input element and
a four attribute to the label element
let's see what happens if we use the
value text for the type attribute in our
input element everything we write is
clearly visible and that is exactly what
we don't want so how can we fix this we
just need to update the type attribute
to the value password and this will
create a password input field where
everything we write is hidden now if we
write our password we just see a
sequence of dots and some browsers might
even display asterisks instead of dots
but either way your password will be
hidden and that's how you can do this in
HTML